- last session for today so then your
weeks with office the NTP research with
the house about spookily homo key
encryption alright great thank you so
thanks for introduction and thank you
for the food organizers for inviting me
and also for access again got how to
make this work really well online so I'm
going to be talking about spookily
homomorphic encryption this is actually
based on my cooking so this is based on
two works one from yorker with broccoli
and one from crystal 2016 with you can
be shy and ran so these are somewhat old
words actually i gave a talk about the
first work and assignments five years
ago in 2015 i was such than a semester
assignment so i gave a talk about it and
actually the second working from a
collaboration that started simon cider
really great time doing that's in a
story with breakfast i'm expecting that
after this dog will start a new
collaboration there'll be another paper
okay so the talk is about three i'm
going to focus on three different
parameters I'll start with fully
homomorphic encryption which I expect
most people already know but I'll just
briefly mention it because they'll let
me frame the other two and then the
focus will be on two new primitives
something called a multi key fully
homomorphic encryption which is sort of
little more fake encryption in the
multi-user studying when there's
multiple users and a stronger version of
that which is called spooky for the
homework encryption and you understand
why it's called spooky during the top so
top focus on these primitives and
roughly divided into three parts so
first I'll tell you what these what
these primitives are what these notions
sue then I'll tell you why why you
should care about them some applications
of them and last I'll tell you a little
bit about how to construct them so let's
start with the what part I'll tell you
what each of these things is so sweet
home of encryption again expect many of
you already know but the it's an idea
that goes back quite a long time but we
only started getting constructions
recently assigned with the work of
gentry in 2009 and the idea is that we
have a user input X and the user can
include
to generate a public key in a secret key
for an encryption scheme and encrypted
in products under the public key so and
that sentence acts like standard public
encryption but there's this extra
amazing capability which is that music
can take the ciphertext and send it to
someone let's say upload it to some call
server and then ask the call to compute
some function evaluate some function f
over the encrypted data so there's some
additional homomorphic evaluation
procedure involved the fix is input a
function f represented as a circuit and
the psychotic c and it outputs a new
circuit X's are oh he started
okay so someone has their microphone on
I think okay so so develop output some
circuits if you start and if you try to
decrypt the user tries to do Christy
start with a secret key they output f of
X essentially they manage to take an
encryption you can take an encryption of
s and converted into an encryption of f
of X or any function f so multi tfhe is
just an extension of this interseting
with many users so now if you hear we
have several users that have different
inputs x1 x2 x3 and in this settings
they can each choose completely
independent public keys and secret keys
so generate their own key pairs and
they're going to increase their data
individually under their own public
okay so you get three different
encryptions of of these different inputs
X 1 X 2 and 3 under different public
keys and so using standards for homework
encryption you cannot really do anything
you can operate on each of these
selected eggs individually but you can't
really do anything that combines all
these inputs and so that's what multi
key fhu lets you do so here there's a
special procedure that lets you evaluate
some function over all 3 over the data
encrypted by all these different cipher
texts that are encrypted under different
keys and derive some slices xB star
now I want to see start to be an
encryption of the output of the function
of the data F of x1 up to X 3 but
encryption under what P who can who can
decrypt least R and if you think about
it it shouldn't be the case that any
individual user should be able to
decrypt this we start because that would
break the security of the other users so
for example if the user with input x1
could be cryptid and that means that you
could learn something about x2 which is
encrypted under a different public key
so no single user should be able to
decrypt the ciphertext C star but so
what we want is that there's a way to
decrypt it given the secret keys of all
the user collaborative or so if all the
users come together they can decrypt
this a protected sexy star and recover
the output of the function on on the
three inputs on X 1 X 10 X 3 and
actually we want something stronger so
we want this to be doable in a very nice
and easy distributed way so actually
they don't have to they don't have to
run some complicate interactive protocol
but actually each user just takes their
own individual secret key and computes a
partial description of the ciphertext C
star so they compute these three partial
descriptions y1 y2 y3 and then you can
combine these to recover f of X so
there's a sense of one round distributed
protocol for decrypting the ciphertext
okay so some background on multi tfhe
this notion was actually originally
proposed by Adriana Iran and Vinod in
2012 and they gave a construction based
on the entry problem and so
unfortunately the construction did not
have a nice distributed decryption
procedure there was no easy way for the
parties to decrypt the final size
objection as simple one-off protocol so
later there was a construction given by
clear McGoldrick from the basic algebra
problem and they had a really nice idea
they really showed how to do this it was
a somewhat complicated construction it
took us a long time to understand was
doing and there was no they didn't talk
about this distributed decryption
procedure which I should mention is
actually crucial for a lot of
applications and so in a paper with
Sakai we simplify this construction of
clear McGoldrick we serve sort of give a
framework for how to understand it and
we show that actually it's pretty easy
to add this distribute and decryption to
this construction I'm Danielle listen
question from Alex Grillo is there some
notion of secret sharing namely that why
I does not leak information with X oh
yeah there should be yes it should be a
secure distributed decryption so that no
single you need to get all the partial
descriptions together to recover the
output so so actually that something's
already implied by by semantic security
because no subset of the party should be
able to figure out the output on their
own that would bring the security of the
party that's left out so Daniel when
there isn't distributed decryption does
that mean that like there's a decryption
algorithm just takes all the secret keys
or how does that write it
all right it some complicated algorithm
that takes all the secret keys and does
a complicated process to to figure out
the data but there's no easy way to
distribute this algorithm by you know in
one round let's say I mean you could
send each party could just send their
secret key but that would break their
own security so you want something you
want something that some extra secure
features that you essentially this these
partial description don't reveal
anything other than the output I see I
see
yeah okay so this is the the background
was known before and then I want to get
to the last notion which is bookie
silicon morphic encryption and so this
notion might seem a little less natural
but III think it's really conception
interesting so someone spend some time
on it
so here the set up is the same as in
multi key fhe we still have several
parties and they each they all choose
their own individual key pairs and they
encrypt their individual data under
their individual keys so you have
encryption of X 1 X 2 and X 3 under
these three different public keys now
they send the data to classes so far
everything is the same as in a multi key
setting but now instead of asking the
eval function to compute a single
ciphertext we're going to ask the valve
to action do some complicated operation
on all all of these community projects
and output three different types of
zextras three different users so it
doesn't open one cypher text for that
they all collaboratively decrypt it
computes instead a three individual
cypher text one for each of the users
and now each of the users decrypt their
own ciphertex with their own secret keys
and get some values y1 y2 and y3 ok so
we start with some inputs x1 x2 x3 we
encrypt them we run it through some
process and then produce three outputs i
projects that are then decrypted to get
these outputs y1 y2 y3 and so the
question is what kind of relationships
can you achieve between the inputs that
come into this process and the outputs
that you derive so you converting
encryptions of excellence text and int
encryption y1 y2 i why and what
relationships between the XS and the Y's
can you can you achieve so one simple
observation is that you cannot get
signaling relationship because of the
semantic security of the encryption so
what I mean by signaling so you can show
that for any subset of the output if I
look at the output
for this subset of the parties the
subset of parties capital I they cannot
depend on the input of the other parties
that don't belong to the subset if that
happened if that was the case that means
that somehow this salsa party special I
can break the security of the encryption
of parties that don't belong to it which
are not which should not happen if you
cannot signal you cannot communicate
broken encryptions under one piece
encryptions under different data cannot
flow between a communication cannot flow
between a piece on the other hand you
can achieve local relationships so each
why I can be an arbitrary function
applies to the X I and that's just by
using standard fully homomorphic
encryption so we can do signaling we can
do local maybe if you haven't seen this
before you might think well that settles
the whole problem but they turns out
that actually surprising with our things
are in between there are relationships
that are neither local nor signaling and
the question is can you can you achieve
these types of relationships so here let
me give you an example so for example
what if can I ensure so there's in the
two party case when n is two can I
ensure that the outputs y 1 and y 2 XOR
to the end of X 1 and X 2 so if you
think about this so this would be like y
1 y 2 are secret sharing of X 1 and X 2
so each one of them each Y I might not
reveal might be independent might just
be a random value and independent of
both X 1 X 2 so this does not signal
because each Y is just random it doesn't
tell you anything about them but if you
look at the Y's together if you look at
the two of them they sum up to the end
of X 1 X 2 and this is not something you
can do by just setting each Y eyes a
local function of X I okay so so this
relationship is also called the CH SH
game I believe in spreading in quantum
and some interesting relations to
quantum mechanics which I'll talk about
on the next slide but this question
obnoxious
I work at all and they ask this in a
real interesting context they actually
noticed that there was a previous paper
that did something very interesting but
their security proved implicitly assume
that there you cannot you cannot do this
you cannot take some x 1x and introduce
y1 yn that would satisfy some not local
but not signalling relationship like
let's say the relationship over here
Daniel K yeah so sorry one clarification
so in home Orphic encryption usually the
evolution function is a publicly
computable so that means that all three
parties can compute all three cipher
texts yeah yeah so it is not if so if
you have a single out except for
efficiency reason so the ciphertext that
could be a concatenation of all three
things and you can still think of it has
been a single ciphertext so let's go
back to the previous life so I want each
party to so the output consists of three
ciphertext and each party outputs it
sounds like as decrypted some type
attacks oh and they don't guys so they
don't get to see the other input sign
yeah they don't talk to each other like
I'm outputting
three sides but that's for three parties
they don't talk to each other and each
one vocally decrypt but they even with
some function is working on all three
sides
exactly so it computable but not
everybody is all the inputs exactly well
not everyone can output can decrypt all
the all the outputs right each
ciphertext can be decrypted by if I just
want that it's supposed to be decrypted
by just one party so essentially we're
saying we're encrypting some excess
under understand vector of access under
individual public keys and we're
computing on the entire vector to get a
vector Y encrypted under the same public
keys respectively and the question is
what relationships between the X's and
Y's can we achieve so we can do
operations under each public individual
that corresponds to local this local
relationship we cannot signal so any any
why
I cannot contain information about XJ
for J not equal to I or any subset of Y
ice cannot contain information about any
excess and are outside of that subset
but then the question is about these
types of relationships over here that
are neither local nor signaling okay I
see this no can you go back to the
previous slide yeah so so usually when
you encrypt something under a public key
you think of it as being already you
know protected here you are assuming
that the cipher texts are sent to eval
through a secure channel so that other
people can not even get to see the
cipher no no I'm not I'm not I'm not
making any such so eval is sort of
therefore a correctness not a security
reason so so the the the security
property is just standard encryption
security semantic security okay there's
no other security property and the
functionality properties that I'm
requiring is the following is that just
evolved words and all the ciphers and
produces a vector of encrypted output
and now gives each output to one party
who just doesn't have the secret so
first party as they don't secretly
doesn't a secret ease of others and
decrypt the first ciphertext and that's
how I generate the why okay so there the
person gets to see everything but for
correctness and the party search should
be able to compute only locally exactly
yeah as a security is just standard
semantic security in each encryption
hides in the encryption side the data
this is a corrector so the spooky
property of the correctness property I
want to I want to ensure or I want to
generate some relationship between the
outputs Y and then put that Dania so
that's a question from the audience
asking what whether it is necessary for
CI and CI prime to be secrets
so I know it's not so again the secure
proper standard encryption security so
so the ciphertext should hide the
encrypted input yeah okay
so the question is you know with the
restriction of standard encryption
security
what kind of correctness property can
read what kind of relationships between
the encrypted input and encrypted output
can we generate and in fact this was
originally asked in a question in the
context of actually not wanting to
generate interesting relationships
originally this was asked because there
was a very interesting worry that
constructed some variant of snark
that essentially made the assumption
that if you do this if you get a bunch
of encrypted X's and produce a bunch of
encrypted Y then it means that each Y
can only be a local function of the
corresponding X and and something's not
clear that's generically true and so
we're asking that so so the question is
can you actually create some non-local
relationships as well so I just want to
give up as a chronology this is actually
very related to something people study
in the setting of quantum physics so
here imagine there's two users that are
on different planets that are I don't
know light-years away they can't talk to
each other because the communication
takes too long to get from one to
another and now each of these people
gets I'm going to get some input X I and
has to produce an output Y I and the
question is what relationship between
the X's under y can these people can can
you get and so because they're on
different planets like you know like
your weight light-years away and they
cannot communicate you can show that
this is a relationship cannot be
signalling so why do cannot depend on X
1 and y 1 cannot depend on X 2
it's easy to do local relationships that
why one can be any function of X 1 y 2
can be an a function of X 2 but the
question is can you do something in
between these non-local but not so
signaling relationships and very
surprisingly if using the traffic
quantum physics if these parties share
some quantum entanglement ahead of time
then they can actually do this it can
generate some non-local relationship not
singular relationships between the y's
and x's for example exactly the
relationship i mentioned the last slide
where the why i our secret shares of x1
and x2 of the and of x1 x2 so you can at
least do this with better than trivial
probabilities okay so so Einstein so
this was a spooky fact about quantum
physics that we call this spooky and
that's why we call this in the
encryption setting call it spooky
encryption so I just want to explain the
analogy a little better so ah so we have
the physical setting the cryptographic
settings from the physical settings the
messages the exits the inputs are
separated by being far apart so the two
parties can't communicate about the
inputs to each other because they're too
far apart and in the cryptographic
settings the inputs are separated
because they're encrypted under
different keys so the two x's are
encrypted under different public keys
therefore you cannot send information
from one public key to another public
key doesn't violate semantic security so
so exactly that shows that signaling
strategies cannot be done the physical
settings because of communication cannot
happen faster in light and in the
cryptographic setting because you
violate semantics appears on the other
hand it turns out in physical setting
it's possible to realize some mounting
links strategies by quantum entanglement
and then the question is can you do
something similar in the cryptographic
setting and that's exactly it was the
goal of spooky friction a Daniel yeah
used about whether I should be thinking
of this as like a counter example like
look this thing exists so therefore when
I try to prove when you try to prove
things you have to consider this
possibility or is it like an actual
thing that I want to use for
applications is there a difference I
mean both so so I'm gonna talk about
some applications of this but yeah it's
also a counter example so people have
tried to build I've tried to use the
fact or rely on the fact that this
cannot be done and so this shows that
you cannot rely on that but I might
actually want to do this spooky thing
it's not just security yeah yeah that's
right so so so this in this talk I shall
show you how to do this kind of outer
get these types of spooky relationship
under lwe can actually generate large
positive relationships between taxes and
the why and in particular can get the
following class of relationships or call
them added a function sharing spooky so
for any function app you can make sure
that the Y eyes are just a secret
sharing and added a secret sharing of
the applies to all the input you can
compute any function on their input and
make sure that the resulting Y are
secret sharing of of the output of that
function okay
this is one entrepreneurs question it
turns out that the cookie fully
homomorphic encryption you can think of
it as a very special type of multi tfhe
with a really easy distributive
decryption so if I think of the
encryptions of y1 up to Y n has the one
ciphertext as one ciphertext that is
generated by the multi tfhe then it has
a really easy way of of decrypting it in
a distributing what matter where the
first party just decrypt the first
component and outputs y1 the second
party y2 and so on so the partial
descriptions are just the Y I and then
the party send them and you just sum
them up to get the output so this is a
spooky of a cheese and sometimes as a
special case of multi tfhe with a very
simple distribute description where the
party just locally decrypt and get a
secret share of the output and just send
the secret shares and phone them up
you
okay so so why do I care about these so
there's a couple of different reasons
I'm only going to mention really one
application which is the two round
multi-party computation but there are a
couple of other applications very
related to function secret sharing and
homomorphic secret sharing and also no
mention there's also Chris do some
interesting counter examples so let me
just tell you about the applications to
round multi-party computation so in
multi-party computation we have several
parties that have some inputs x1 and x2
and so on and they want to compute some
function on these insults and they do
this by running a protocol where
correctness says that they compute the
function and security says that nothing
else is revealed except the output of
the function and the question is how
many how many rounds do you need to do
this so previously there were results
that show how to do this even in
constant number of rounds but in control
that actually need at least two rounds
and wasn't clear if you could do it in
exactly two rounds and so with this
multi key filler morphic encryption you
get an incredibly simple multi-party
computation protocol that works in two
rounds so here each party just chooses
their own public key and secret key pair
and broadcast the encryption of its
inputs under its own public key then all
the parties are so this is just a first
round each party just sends an
encryption of its input
at the end of the first round the
parties just each all the parties
individually run the homework evaluation
algorithm and compute the ciphertext
restart that encrypts the output of the
function so we can think of the eval of
the homework evaluation is being
deterministic so each party can just do
this on their own and they all get the
same output ciphertext C star and then
in the second round the parties run and
distributed description protocol so each
party sent this partial description of C
star and then you just you use these
partial descriptions to recover the
output Y so it gives you an incredibly
simple format for a two round and bc
given a multi tfhe and if you have a
spooky encryption you actually did
something a little better so at the end
of the first round already the parties
to compute an additive secret sharing
come to output so you have a one round
and bc protocol where the parties don't
get output itself but they get a secret
sharing of the output at the end of the
first round and then the second one just
consists of all the parties sending out
their shares
okay so the last part is talking I'm
going to tell you how to actually do
this and so I'm going to start by
telling you about just basic fully
homomorphic encryption this will be the
gem trees behind water scheme I believe
you already heard about at the beginning
of the workshop from motive stuff so
this will be just a quick summary and
we're going to see how to use these
techniques to extend them to ball to get
both multi key fhe and spooky ihe
okay so let's recall the Gentry's tahai
and waters putting on market encryption
see so here the public key is just a
matrix a and it has this format where
the top top and minus 1 rows or oh all
except the last row of the public here
just uniformly random so called n matrix
D and then the last row is just an LW
sample with this matrix P such as a
random linear combination of the rows of
B plus some noise
cookie is just this vector s which is
the linear combination selective suction
negative as can NATO is one and you
don't really like to remember much about
this except for this last property so
the relationship between the public um
speaker key is that if you take the
secret key and multiply it by to the
public key you get a small to small
error vector e so you get something
small and I'll just write these squiggly
lines to denote small things so I'll say
the secret key times the public key is
essentially zero
and I want to mention that the top part
of this matrix this matrix B you can
think of that as a common public
parameter people don't need to have any
trapdoors for that so we can just
generate that once and for all and all
all parties can use the same we can
always use the same beam when we
generate soft and fresh public key
sensitivities
okay so to encrypt some input X some bit
X under this public key encryption
algorithms at the bottom it just takes
the public key ke this a matrix andrey
randomizes it by multiplying it on the
right by a square matrix with short
entries but they just random 0 1 entries
and and then we add the bit X I'm some
gadget matrix G and I think you already
heard about the gadget matrix I'll
mention more what we need from that in a
little bit okay so this is the cipher
text and again you don't really need to
remember much about this you just need
to remember the main property which is
that if you say the secret key are
multiplied by the ciphertext
you've got the bit X that was encrypted
times the secret key times the gadget
matrix G
okay so that's the encryption procedure
and this actually also automatically
gives us a way to decrypt because if X
is zero then this whole vector will be
very close to zero and if X is 1 then
this vector will have some large entries
so by checking if this vectors goes to
zero or not you can recover X
so the security of this team is it's
really easy to show it follows in one
long year so if I give you the public
key a and a ciphertext AR + XG this is
some encryption of X then by lwe a isn't
distinguished from the random matrix u
so this looks like you and you Times
article that G and by the leftover hash
lemma u times R looks like a random
independent value so if I give you the
public key ciphers actually just look
like random and independent - random
independent matrices
okay so how do we do the homomorphic
evaluation that's really the interesting
part so soon likes to ciphertext C 1 and
C 2 that encrypt this X 1 and X 2
respectively so by the way it turns out
to compute the value 8 and its circuit
on encrypted data it's sufficient if I
can do addition and multiplication
those are complete operations if I can
encrypt and multiply bits I can evaluate
any circuit so here to ciphertext that
encrypt some bits X 1 and X 2 and I want
to derive ciphertext that encrypts the
sum of the bed as well as the product of
the bit so addition is really easy I'm
just going to add the ciphertext and you
can see that the same property holds if
I this resulting ciphertext just
encrypts the sum of the base if I
multiplied by the secrecy on the left I
get X 1 plus X 2 times T times G which
was the property I want
what about
multiplication the texture only slightly
harder and so I would expect that I
would just multiply the selected X
together that doesn't really work
they're not even the right dimension but
it's almost the same thing I just
multiplied c1 by some function of c2
I'm going to call this function and G
inverse function so G inverse is a
function such as G times G inverse of C
is equal to C it's not real and matrix
inverse because G is not a square matrix
but it outputs a value where so G
inverse of C up to some value such if I
multiply on the left by G I get D and
also G inverse of C should have small at
least that's actually show okay so and
we have such a gadget which is just a
public we have such a gadget matrix G
and for which such a function G inverse
exists and is easy to compute okay so
with this with this with this way of
multiplying the cipher text that I guess
it's a simple calculation can check that
it actually does correctly encrypt the
product of the two bits x 1 x X 2 D G P
so this lets me do addition and
multiplication therefore I can evaluate
any circuit on encrypted data you need
to keep in mind that as I'm doing these
operations there's some noise in the
cipher text that I'm hiding and this
noise grows as the S you're doing
computation in the circuit X and so in
some sense you have to choose your
parameters you have to choose your
modulus to be large enough to handle the
big noise that you get at the output
level so the efficiency here degrades
with the depth of the circuit D but it
turns out you can fix this by a booth
traffic
so this is so far baseless fully
homomorphic encryption and now we're
going to see how to use this how the
data is to get multi key Solihull mark
encryption so we're going to try to stay
as close to the GS w encryption scheme
as possible and just going to create a
multi key version of it so here we're
imagining a scenario where we have n
party and these parties generate
independent key pairs public antiquities
of the GSM new encryption scheme except
that they're going to use when they
change the public keys they're going to
reuse the same matrix P so we're
thinking of that matrix P as some common
public parameter or common reference
strings that all parties use
okay so in the scenario each part of the
eyes has some secret ETI and and it's
data is encrypted with respect to the
secret key I'm going to define an
expanded secret key which just consists
of the contamination of all the secret
ease of all the parties so I'm just
going to contaminate them together and
call that vector T hat and I'm going to
call that the expanded secret key and my
goal will be to take any ciphertext that
an individual party I encrypt and
somehow converted into a safer sex the
dial is that decrypt correctly under
this expanded secret key I'm Michael and
expanding multi key cipher text so what
I want is to take some ciphertext C that
is a good encryption of X under the
secret key party I so satisfies this
property and convert it into an expanded
ciphertext which is a good encryption of
the same bit X under the expanded secret
key key hack and everything goes to your
girls so also the gadget matrix 0 grown
we're going to give this expanded gadget
matrix but it turns out the expanded
gadget matrix has the same properties as
the basic gadget matrix so this is okay
and I claim if I can do this I'm done
I'm almost done so if I can convert any
individual party ciphertext into this
expanded ciphertext then to do an app to
do homomorphic computation on ciphertext
encrypted by many parties I'm just going
to take all those individual sectors X
convert them all into this expanded
format convert them into expanded
ciphertext under the combined hundreds
expanded key t hat and now all the
ciphertext under the same secret et hat
so I can perform homomorphic operations
on them the same way I worked on basic g
SW ciphertext so just the dimensions
grow but every otherwise everything else
is exactly the same so I can then
compute on all these ciphertext because
on all these expanded psychotics because
they are all under the same key in
england expanded EE hat so the hard part
is how to do this step how to convert a
ciphertext of one party into this
expanded multi key cipher text under the
keys under this concatenated hundred
expand the key that contaminates the
piece of all the parties so let's do
this for any Costa two parties and I
claim everything that was extends
naturally to more than two parties as
well so once you see how to did for two
parties you it's sort of the same thing
for more okay so here so here we have
two different public keys and secret
keys for two parties one and two so we
have public key one a one and secretly
152 and sixty two and we have some
encryption party one encryption of an
input X so this is the cipher text which
in of cardi one which encrypts some
input X and our goal will be to convert
that into this expanded ciphertext under
the combined under the expanded key of
both party one answers so we're not
going to be able to do that as this
we're going to need some additional help
info that's our t1 roll release so the
encryption of party one of each is the
individual encryption of each party is
not going to just be GSW going to me
GSLV
from additional helper data that is TBD
I'll tell you in a little bit for that
what that needs to be okay so so we take
the cypher text of party one we know
that satisfies this property if you try
to decrypt this so if you multiply it on
the left by the secret to your party 1
you get X T 1 G
so what happens if you try to decrypt
the ciphertext of party one with the
secret key of party - that seems like a
really bad idea I mean it's a schema
secure this really shouldn't work so if
you've got the right you know output if
you managed to recover X that would
break the secure the scheme that would
break lwe
that would break lattice assumptions and
we don't have to go home so let's see
what happens hopefully it won't work so
if you follow this equations well it
actually almost works you actually get X
T 2g but you also get some additional
blinding factor which is just b1 minus
b2 so these are the two public key
components of parties one and two
subtracted from each other times R where
R was the encryption randomness so
essentially if you try to decrypt
parties one ciphertext with secret key -
you get the right output but it's
blinded by this value over here so
here's the idea
so this gives us an idea for how the
craziest expanded ciphertext so we have
this ciphertext e of party one that
decrypt correct mantra donkey and we
want to convert it into psycho text that
decrypt scratch
directly under the contamination of the
seat of the beast and so here's idea how
to do that we're going to define this
expanded ciphertext C hat and this way
so where I'll tell you how to choose the
matrix D in in a second so call that
unmask turn because it's going to try to
cancel out this value over here
okay so if I define C head this way that
when I decrypted by the expanded secret
key I get almost what I want so I get X
t1 g on the last and I want to get X t2
g on the right but I'm going to get the
blind turn over here plus t1 D so I want
to choose D carefully so that t1 D is
equal to b2 minus b1 hours that they
cancel out okay so now again what this
shows is that in order to be able to use
the encryption of party one the site
protected party 1 and expanded into this
expanded ciphertext my goal is to
somehow define what to have party 1 stem
addition sent some additional offering
so they would let me compute a matrix D
that satisfies this property
so I need to show you how to do that
that's the last step so yeah so I need
to show you how party one can can give
some additional help info that will let
us compute this matrix C that satisfies
this property here and here's the idea
the idea is that the helper info is just
going to consist of GS of the encryption
of the random lands of each bit of the
randomness are used to create the GSLV
ciphertext of party 1
so remember party 1 generated I am
Michael Douglas Feith the party 1
generated this GSW circuit activated
acts and then we're going to take this
randomness R that is used to encrypt it
and we're going to take that and we're
going to encrypt it again under the same
using the same scheme so we're going to
create many ciphertext for each phase of
this of this random map
so this I protect satisfy this property
and it turns out that by doing fairly
simple homomorphic operation on this
ciphertext we can derive this matrix D
that satisfies the property we want it
so in particular you can think of this
as a humming worker computation that has
encryption of the random lekar and it
knows the values that public is b1 and
between the clear and homomorphic click
computes an encryption of b2 minus b1
times R now it's not quite quite this is
not quite right because here the
psychotics decrypt the vector when
decrypt your Messing's matrix g so it
doesn't it's not exactly a standard
homomorphic computation on GSLV
ciphertext but it turns out this is
something you can do pretty easily with
the GS w scheme and so that that's
really was soft entire problem
okay so so sorry that this was a little
bit of a messy algebra but once once we
do this we're really done and we're able
to take individual ciphertext under the
GSW scheme and convert them into these
expanded ciphertext then we can do all
of the homeotic operation on the
explanatory text and we get an
encryption of the output under the
contamination of the piece so so we're
done we're able to compute an encryption
of the output under the condition the
key now let's see how to do a
distributed decryption so again we have
this expanded secret key which is just
the contamination of all the individual
secret key and we have this expanded
ciphertext we have that decrypt the
output in this case was some value X and
satisfies this property so now we want
to come up with a way to decrypt the
ciphertext in a very simple one round
distributed manner where parties don't
reveal information about their secret
key other than just the output other
than the values the psychotics encrypts
then yeah there's a question from the
audience roughly speaking does the party
one somehow need to know parties to
identity to computer sabotage correctly
because it looks like party one needs to
know be to good no it does not
so let's go back here I guess is my
state so party one is just computing its
encryption see of the bit axe that it's
under GSW so has nothing to do with with
d2 and it's also altering this offer
info so the health info is just
encryptions of the randomness that it
used to compute the years of the
encryption of X hundreds on public key
so again here you don't know anything
about d2 what where where b2 does come
in is that once you have the helper info
you can and once you have the whole
principal you want to use it to take
this encryption under party one key and
expanded into this expanded ciphertext
so there at that point you do know the
identity of party to okay so that that's
when you know b2 and and you can compute
this matrix D which depends on P 2 and
that's going to let you generate the
expanded ciphertext so again parties are
crippling their data individually once
everyone encrypts and you have all the
different hypertext then you can expand
them together into an expanded
ciphertext under all the keys here I'm
assuming you know all the public keys
and all the sacrifice at this point ok
so let's go back to how to do distribute
decryption so again we have this
expanded ciphertext which is the big
matrix and we know that it satisfies
this property state expanded ciphertext
x the expanded key you get the output
times T times G so the first step is
going to be well I don't want to have
this T in the decryption I wanted to do
a distributed decryption where I recover
X times where I didn't recover this
whole thing because that would reveal
something about all the secret ease he
had and that would be bad so I want to
somehow get rid of t hat in there and
that's an easy stuff I'm just gonna
multiply this expanding Cyprus X by G
inverse of W where W is just the all 0
vector except for a queueing over 2 in
the last component and what that
essentially does is that I get an extra
C hat I get this compressed ciphertext
we had such as if I multiply the
compressed ciphertext by if I think then
your product is the compressed I protect
and expand the key I just get x times T
over 2 so this relies on the fact that
he had has a 1 in the very last
components of P hat times W is just G
over 2 in a proxy hemant up is just K
over 2 ok so now I I I compress down
this big I expand aside protection to
some long vector C hat and my entire
decryption procedure just consists of
taking an inner product of this
ciphertext we had with the contamination
of all the secret keys so that sometimes
can do in an easy distributed manner in
fact of just the first party can just
again in a product of this secret key
with the first part of the ciphertext C
1 the second party with the second front
so long so essentially each party is
just gonna again in a product of its
secret key with the corresponding
component of the of this of the second
taxi and then we're just going to take
all of these Y I and some of them and we
get something close to x times P over 2
so by rounding we recover the alphabet
ok so this is the distributed decryption
procedure incurred it was simple it's
just an inner product each part is just
stuff and in a product of a secret key
which part of the ciphertext
so now we want to go to spook encryption
actually if you look at the last slide
we see we're almost there the output of
this encryption was so that the this
psychotic we had which was the result of
the homogeny valuation action does
consist of an individual ciphertext and
essentially what we're doing is just
decrypting them just taking the inner
product and summing up but there is a
little bit of a discrepancy so let's see
what the description is it seems like
we're almost there but not quiet and the
problem is that if I think of a
decryption operation a decryption
operation on the in the single T setting
a vision least compress ciphertext would
be to do an inner product followed by a
rounding operation that gives you the
encrypted value X whereas in the multi
key setting so if I want to decrypt the
most key cipher texts I need to do a
bunch of these I might need to design a
project on all of the components sum
them up and then round this off to
decrypt the multi key cipher text I sum
up these partial decryption and then
round them whereas in spooky encryption
we want to individual decryption and get
X so what we want is actually just the
order of the rounding and the sum being
reversed so in spooky encryption we want
to we want parties to individual decrypt
their data and then just have that be an
additive secret sharing of the encrypted
value so we want to first wrong and then
from that's actually the entire
difference
are we doing something and then rounding
or rounding and that's coming
so unfortunately these two operations
are not the same in general but it turns
out that they are the same when for two
in the two party case when n is equal to
two so turns out that if you sum up two
values and then round them this is the
same as rounding and coming up the
values so this only works I should have
mentioned this only work with the sum of
the values is either close to 3 over 2
or 0 the vector values that are either
close to P over 2 or 0 then these two
operations are equivalent they both give
you so summing and rounding is the same
as rounding and summing and the proof is
our simple proof by picture so if x 2
values are very close to 0 then that
means they're either very close together
stops or two values whose sum is so so I
have two values that are either very
close together in which case if I round
then I get the same value so to sum up
to 0 or X 2 values are on the opposite
end of the circle so that's something
like one value here and one value here
and then chances are if I round they
also end up there on the opposite day
okay so it turns out this works for two
but it does not work for more than two
for n equal magnitude so so the good
news is we get spooky for the homework
encryption but only for two parties not
for arbitrary number five so turns out
there is one more trick to go from two
party spooky encryption to many party
spooky encryption and the trick is very
similar to the gmw multi-party
computation so let me show you what this
trick is so it's a genetic trait assume
as I feel even more free encryption that
lets me do spooky operations on two
ciphertext so I can take some
encryptions of x1 encryptions of x2 and
come up with an encryption of
encryptions of y1 and y2 which are
secret sharing of let's say x1 times x2
I claim that enough to then do arbitrary
copies arbitrary additively
spooky relation so here's the idea
assume I want so I'm starting with
encryptions of some inputs x1 up to xn
and my goal is to come up with
encryptions and outputs y1 yn which is
the sum of Y I is an arbitrary function
evaluated on x1 up to xn
okay so this is my goal to create a
spooking fhe for an parties
and the idea is to follow a follow the
gmw and PC approach so we're going to
start minute with an invariant where for
each wire in the circuit I have
encryptions of some values W which are
the secret shares of the values that go
across the circuit
it's like gmw except under encryption
okay and so this invariant can be
satisfied for the input because here I
actually have just an encryption under
public key I have then put on the input
X I so I can just include zeros for all
the other for all the other parties and
I have encryptions of a bunch of values
that sum up to the input X
okay and we're going to show how to
preserve this invariant so if I'm an
addition gate then I'm just going to use
single key homomorphism I'm just going
to use the fact that this encryption
scheme is just additively homomorphic
for in the single key settings so I'm
just going to take all these encryptions
of all these wire values and add them up
component vise
for multiplication gauge it's a little
more complicated but I'm going to just
rely on the fact that I have to party
spooky operations so I can take inputs
of two parties and come up with a wig to
encryptions that secret share that are
encryption of the statistica chain of
the product of these simple
so in particular I have encryptions of
some values they went up to a n that sum
up to a have encryptions of values B 1
up to BN that sum up to B and I want to
come up with encryption with and and I'm
trying to come up with encryptions of a
secret chain of the product of a times B
so here's a way to do this I'm just
going to use the single the two party
tsuki operation to come up with
encryptions of some D and E values that
come up to any product AI times BJ okay
and I'm just going to sum up the
encryptions of this form of any party I
to get these encryptions of CI and now
the C is add up to a times B so this is
the so in the g MW setting we used OT to
do this type of multiplication whereas
here we're using this additive this
pookie homomorphism to be able to
implement this operation but otherwise
it's really the same idea as g MW MDC
that's really all I want to show you so
that shows you how to get cookie home
market encryption so these words are
somewhat old and there's been some real
interesting progress since then so it's
a bit of an epilogue to this so one
question you can ask is can we do to run
multi-party computation without multi
PSHE so multi psht also has these
compactness requirements that don't seem
inherent for a multi-party computation I
mean they're nice to have if you want to
have multi-party computation with low
communication complexity but if I just
care about doing Terron FEC it doesn't
seem that multi tfhe is inherent and
indeed it was shown that it's not
inherent that you can do to run MPC
without doing multi tfhe there's a
really beautiful work by gar concern
about Shannon banana then Lin that show
how to use to round ot to get to round
and PC and you can do this even in the
plane model without STRs
without a comm reference track
another question can have is if you can
construct most icky fhe in the plane
model so if you remember in our
construction we did actually so the
parties chose their public key secret
keys independently except that they had
this common shared matrix B that they
all used and said that there was some
common parameter or common reference
strengths that all the parties needed to
use in order to be able to compute on
the psychotics of all these parties
together and it wasn't clear if you
could get rid of it so there's a really
very recent beautiful work that shows
how to get rid of this I'll construct
multi tfhe and the plane model
unfortunately not from LW directly but
from some combination of entry and LW
a couple of open questions are left so
first obvious open questions can you get
multi tfhe in the play model from LW
alone without requiring the entry
assumption
another one is if I wanted to get
non-compact multi tfhe can I do that
without her lovely so if you want a non
compact fhe it's trivial you just
contaminate the ciphertext the only
interesting aspect of fully homomorphic
encryption is compactness but when it
comes to multi key for the home or fig
encryption even a non compact version
will be interesting for example it would
give you two rounded PC so I I don't
think the two round MVC papers actually
solve this problem directly they don't
give you something that has exactly the
format of multi PSHE so I think it's
still an interesting question even
though we already know how to do two
round and PC from other assumptions like
DDH it's an interesting open question to
really get something that would have the
format of multi tfhe but a non compact
one from things like DD h and the last
question is can you do can you do this
where the complexity of the evaluation
procedure does not scale with the number
of parties so here in our case when we
computed the expanded ciphertext the
expanded sizes are actually quite large
if there are n parties extended cycle
sites will start site at Legion squared
and then we have to compute the circuit
on these expanded like ciphertext so the
complexity of the evaluation procedure
was proportional to the circuit size
times N squared and it's an interesting
question if you can get rid of this so I
mentioned there is some work that
actually does get rid of this but I
believe it's some other deficiencies so
I think it's for an interesting question
to to completely get rid of this and
just get certified times security
grammar and the last of the question is
well we talked about getting spooky
homomorphic encryption can you get
spooky free on the market encryption can
you get a home working encryption scheme
that's guaranteed to not allow and it's
spooky relationship and that would be
very interesting for constructing things
like snort I'm getting rid of yeah so it
would actually be an interesting
security property to ensure that you
cannot generate
relationship yeah yeah I think I was the
open questions so I so I have to be
honest I actually had a chance to read
those papers so I wasn't sure I thought
I saw that they did align LW but there
is that they also there's new papers
that also did on DDA H the parameter
will depend on the number of parties the
pepper tree from my linear map the
parameter would not depend on the number
of parties mm-hmm
what do you mean by parameter parameter
in the sense that you have to know the
number of okay okay I see before
yourself so the parameter scale so is
number of parties exponentially okay and
the other question is about this book
III like home offic encryption I'm like
yeah can you say a little bit about its
relation
encryption yeah yeah so not malleable
encryption is spooky free that's great
but I want spooky free homomorphic
encryption so I want to be able to do
individual I want it to be homomorphic
in the in the single user setting I want
to be able to do local relations like
but I don't want to be able to do I want
to prevent doing creating spooky
relation okay thank you
a few more questions but maybe I can
take them offline Daniel maybe you can
stick around I'm security sure would be
happy to okay great all right so let's
thank all the speakers for today you can
stick around for Q&A
you look read the Q&A and we continue
tomorrow same time with our quantum
talks thanks again everyone